early on in resident evil village ethan
is thrown into the wolf's den and you
get a glimpse of the lords who await you
i was immediately intrigued by their
design and wanted to know more
especially after waking up with a creepy
doll in my face
so here is the lore of resident evil
village's main villains
as a fair warning there will be heavy
spoilers from here on out
it's important to start with miranda and
the cadoo as her tale will help explain
the rest of the four lords
for a super in-depth look at her and the
full ending explained
i'd recommend watching our video on just
that miranda was likely born in the late
1800s to the very same village that
resident evil village takes place in
she had a child named ava who she sadly
lost to the spanish flu which lasted
from 1918 to april 1920.
she was so distraught after losing ava
she wandered into a cave to die
however completely by accident she came
across the mega my seat
upon touching it her mind was overcome
with knowledge
apparently the mega my seat is able to
store the consciousness of everyone
who's died
and come into contact with it the mold
also gave her insane powers
including regenerative abilities the
ability to stop aging
and the unique power to change her
appearance this began her quest to find
a vessel for her daughter's
consciousness
so she could effectively bring her
daughter back from the dead
in order to do this miranda began
experimenting on the various villagers
by implanting them with mold from the
mega my seat
however this wasn't going well and in
order to more efficiently do this
she created a parasite she called kadu
and would administer
shots to the villagers of the town to
infect them with it
why the villagers were okay with this is
a little unclear but i suspect the
answer lies within the end
credits during the scene we see a family
of the village with a young daughter
infected by
what i believe to be the spanish flu
miranda gave them hope with a shot that
could cure the infection
and as we see with the little girl this
actually worked
well on very few of the villagers other
villagers this
turned into lichens miranda also used
her shape-shifting abilities to make
herself appear as a holy angel
we see her likeness as a painting in the
village church and many villagers houses
and she bears a halo as in classical
paintings
on top of this she has given herself
wings which would also give her the look
of an angel coming down to save the
village from disease
we know for certain this is how the
villagers view her as they refer to her
as a mother miranda
giving her a holy title and in a letter
to louisa
one villager laments they broke in again
got more of the livestock
i don't think we'll make it through the
winter at this rate ernest is still
missing too
we can't find him anywhere has mother
miranda
abandoned us they even go so far as to
sacrifice
goats to mother miranda present her with
offerings and offer her goats of warding
for protection
they clearly worship her one more
interesting tidbit related to this is
that miranda is actually the crazy old
lady ethan runs into throughout the game
while some other villagers view her as
looney it seems mother miranda used this
form to propagate legends about herself
and
spread them throughout the village
likely helping to build her holy
image it's important to note that at one
point in time she started up a lab
within the village itself
where she began her research and even
had a team working with her
oswell e spencer the founder of umbrella
corporation
actually studied under her after staying
in her village
spencer notes in a letter that he came
to the village 15 years before writing
it
and mentions this took place after two
world wars and humanity was on the cusp
of another
meaning it was sometime around the cold
war as spencer mentions finding the
progenitor virus which was discovered in
1966
he likely studied with her around 1951
and it was around this time that miranda
would have her first
truly successful experiment alcina
dimitresk
and my apologies if my pronunciation of
her name is a bit off stomach dress
even the game has different
pronunciations alcina dimitressk was the
181st subject who miranda experimented
on
and as miranda herself notes her cadoo
affinity was most favorable
she has a very high affinity and no loss
of cognition
unlike the lykans and other monsters who
lose their higher brain function
she wasn't from the village itself but
rather from the royal de metresque
family and of noble descent
the dimitras were known for creating
wine in their castle and utilizing a
legendary technique
tracing all the way back to the 15th
century alcina who was 44 at the time of
being experimented on
continued the legendary yet peculiar
technique to enrich the wine's flavor
intensity
and bestow it with a thick bouquet her
best vintage is sangui
virginis meaning maiden's blood it is
kept in a special ornate bottle
decorated with intricate silver flowers
we know thanks to the diary of a maid
who came to work for al cena that alsino
was injected with the cadoo
at the very least by 1958. the kadu gave
alcina de metresque an incredible
ability to regenerate at high speed
with the ability to heal any external
wound within seconds
and grow her nails into claws and mere
moments for some reason
this rapid regeneration led to an
increase in her overall body size
and the advent of the lady d everyone
knows and loves
however there was one major flaw with
that being a hereditary blood disease
she was born with
possibly passed on through her noble
family for some reason this blood
disease leads to her vampiric nature
after being infected with the could do
and her need to regularly ingest human
flesh and blood to maintain her
regeneration properties
in order to accelerate finding the
perfect specimen for ava
miranda gave lady dimitresk kadu to
inject into her subjects and others
working in the castle
we find a guest ledger early on in
castle dimitresk
it's very possible this ledger relates
to just a month before ethan arrived
as there's no year associated with it it
could also refer to a certain
important event and if that's the case
we know that on a certain january 5th
an employee named rednick delivered one
male and three females
with those three females likely bella
cassandra and daniela
later on january 28th mother miranda met
with alcena which could have been to
give her the kadu to administer to the
lot
after being treated the daughters bodies
became covered in flies that appeared to
consume their flesh
however these flies eventually took on
the shape of a human and changed color
to resemble that of the human with pale
faces and deep crimson lips
after awakening the three looked at el
cena de metresque like newborns
and she sensed a bond between them like
mother and daughters
apparently they truly were newborns and
the three original daughters dead
these flies are carnivorous and
vigorously consume meat
in order to catch unsuspecting prey
they'll gather using pheromones to mimic
a human
they're produced when a kadu lays eggs
in its host
but the flies themselves are unable to
reproduce
so it seems to me the kadu laid eggs in
the young girls and those could do
flies then mimicked their shape and
human form
clearly the virus affects everyone a
little differently in fact these flies
specifically can't handle the cold
weather
not only giving the player a tip on how
to defeat the daughters but also
explaining why one of the maids was
disposed of for opening a window
either way lady dimitresque was so taken
with them
she adopted them as her daughters and
the three black roses she wears near her
heart
represent her three daughters her
daughters meanwhile
each have a flower tattoo on their
forehead it's also worth noting that
while lady dimitrisk needs to ingest
human flesh and blood to maintain her
ability to regenerate
we're only told her daughters need to
consume meat this is probably why we see
hunks of meat strung up in the kitchen
however lady demetresque requires human
flesh
specifically so with that we turn to the
dungeons and torture chambers
as we learn from a poor maid there were
so many souls being tortured the wailing
rang through the halls sounding like
ghosts
after making a mistake she's brought
down to the cellar where we see
just what kind of treatment she'll
receive here we see horrifying devices
meant to poke and prod blood out of
their victim
blood lady demetresque would be able to
drink from we also find bodies hanging
over barrels
likely meant to collect their blood for
lady demontresque storage
not only that but lab equipment and the
serum to inject victims with kadu
we find a list of treatment candidates
with candidates and rejects
i believe the rejects were tortured for
their blood and the candidates would
receive an injection of the cadoo
possibly after being tortured for blood
because you know
a girl's gotta eat these candidates
would then transform into the
zombie-like creatures we see roaming the
halls as we can confirm thanks to one of
the four listed candidates
ingrid most are listed as having robust
appetites
which matches with the zombies attempts
to eat ethan and one specifically drops
ingrid's
necklace upon killing it confirming this
another one was sent to the seller she'd
only spilled some
soup everyone knows what happens when
you're sent to the cellar
you're never seen again they drain your
blood your soul cursed to wander the
halls
i went looking for her and when i found
her she was just skin
and bones and gnawing on a rat carcass
i suspect it'll be my turn next as it
would turn out
while all men were drained of their
blood without ever being turned
only the woman of the castle were turned
into the maraca we see
roaming the halls this blood is then
used to make lady demetresques of wine
lady dimitresk and her daughters seem to
specifically despise men
and hire an all-female staff starting to
go a little steady then let's devour his
man flesh quickly mother
you lay your filthy manhands on
my daughters word of the vampiric lady
did evidently spread throughout the
village
cloves of garlic hanging can be found
everywhere in the village
although unfortunately for them unlike a
traditional vampire
these girls have no hidden weakness to
garlic and even hang them in their own
kitchen
an assassin would come with the dagger
of death's flowers to try and kill lady
dymatresk
he failed his mission and she sealed
both him and his corpse away in her
tower as the dagger was still a threat
to her
next we come to the tragic tale of donna
beneviento and angie
donna was born to the noble beneviento
family who it seems was related to
barangario
one of the four founders of the village
and its surroundings
we know that this family was noble and
that they had hired help who attended to
their needs
such as the gardener yosef simone donna
beneviento and claudia benoviento were
two daughters to this noble family
donna beneviento was born with a scar on
her face which left her shy and fearful
of others throughout her childhood
the only photo or rather painting we
find of donna in the game
shows her looking quite normal just
holding her creepy doll angie
however that's a painting and it was
probably painted specifically to not
show her scarring
there is concept art of donna that shows
a little more of her
after she's been infected by the cadoo
and with her morning garb draped away
from her face
while half of her face is infected you
can also see blood dripping down from
around her forehead
next to her we see the doll angie a doll
that her father made for her when she
was younger
given donna's attachment to angie and
the fact that angie has strange scarring
across her own face
including a third eye on her forehead
this leads me to believe that angie was
actually made to represent donna
therefore giving her a playmate she
could relate to so it's pretty likely
i think that this scar we see across
angie's face
and even the third eye are exactly what
a young donna was dealing with making it
understandable why she would be so shy
unfortunately we don't know
too much about claudia beneviento other
than that she was probably donna's
little sister
and definitely meant a lot to her
tragically claudia who was born in 1987
died at the young age of just nine years
old and was buried with baron gario's
chalice
a family heirloom we find dolls and the
flower that donna used to create
hallucinations all
over this massive grave showing its
importance to not only the beneviento
family
but also to donner herself tragically
claudia wouldn't be the only family
member donna would lose as her parents
would also somehow die
after this donna locked herself away in
mourning and would only speak to her
doll angie
notably this would have been around or
after 1996.
and it seems around this time mother
miranda gave donna a visit and injected
her with the cadoo
i say that it seems that way based on
what we learned from the gardener
in the game's concept art we're told
that the scarred part of her face was
caused by the parasite
her base concept is that she's a ghost
if she had this scarring as a child and
it was caused by the parasite that would
mean she was actually injected far
earlier and only recently came into
favor with miranda
donna ended up another of the favorable
candidates with the kadu giving her
strange powers
physically she's no different from a
regular human however she can secrete a
signal producing substance which
controls plants infected by the muta my
seat
when humans absorb the pollen from a
particular flower she can cause them to
have hallucinations
however she is mentally underdeveloped
and has divided her cadoo among her
dolls in order to control them from a
distance
as miranda notes donna has a severe
mental illness
although it's unclear if this is as a
result of the cadoo or
one she already had also this explains
why the dolls move
they actually also have a part of
donna's could do in them which we see
when destroying angie
and hence why this also kills donna this
isn't the only ability she has though
and the alkaloids of a certain yellow
mountainous flower allow her to give
people hallucinations
she therefore has yosef plant these
flowers in the garden
which he also chooses to plant in front
of claudia's grave
it gives him hallucinations of his
departed wife which donna uses to coax
him into the beneviento manor
to see his family and where he is likely
mentally tortured
and slain the second lives deep in a
valley of mist
the doll maker donna beneviento
none of her playmates have ever come
back from that dank old
state it seems that donna's mental
illness has made her keep to herself and
coax people to be her twisted child like
playmates
while there is a lab we don't really see
any references to kudu being used or
injected in people here
so it's likely due to her mental illness
and spreading her gdu amongst her dolls
miranda didn't trust her with this
the third is moreau a being of twisted
flesh that lives in the reservoir past
the windmills
[Music]
it is said that he is not the only
monster that lives in those waters
there actually isn't too much we know
about salvatore moreau
other than he wasn't mentally sound we
do know that he enjoys watching old
romance movies and
really enjoys eating cheese both from
the concept art
and from the giant block of cheese we
can find in this chamber
he likely lived in the fishing village
we find him in but at some point miranda
injected him with the cadoo
and he had a a slightly better reaction
than most
that said his affinity to the kadu was
low and
either as a result of the injection or
just in general
he was extremely dimwitted as miranda
notes the could do caused
drastic changes to his internal organs
transforming them into organs similar to
fish like gills and a swim bladder
another subject with a regular cell
division causing him to transform into a
giant fish
the subject is unable to control this
transformation
it seems that fits of uncontrollable
vomit and pus are a telltale sign he's
about to transform
while moreau wasn't the sharpest tool in
the shed miranda did trust him with
performing more cadoo experiments
she also gave him a mountain where he
started a laboratory
and in one particular instance of
inspiration morrow tried injecting wolf
blood into a cadoo experiment's spine
this turned the subject into one of the
giant wolf-like monsters we see
throughout the game
moreau sees himself as an adopted child
of miranda's and is exceedingly upset
that she's trying to bring her real
daughter back
as he himself notes none of the other
children like him
and he thinks mother miranda does he's
afraid that she'll abandon him after ava
is brought back to life
as he's kind of a hopeless romantic as
indicated by his love of old romance
movies
it's very possible that he's in love
with miranda is thereby willing to do
terrible things for her
and is completely jealous of ethan sadly
as he's unaware she never cared for him
in the first place
and was only using him finally
we come to carl heisenberg the very
first of the lords that we meet
and the most powerful his affinity to
the cadoo is
incredibly favorable and his brain still
functions normally
as miranda states the cadoo has given
him electric organs similar to the
electric gray narkei japonica
these electric organs are connected to
the subject's nervous system
he can therefore pass and control
electricity throughout his entire
body allowing him control of magnetic
fields which are used to move metal
the cadoo has given him his magneto-like
abilities however
heisenberg strongly detests miranda
while he plays nice in front of her
he has been using the kadu she supplies
him with to experiment on creating an
entire army to wipe her out unlike the
others
it seems that he uses cadavers to
experiment on as opposed to the living
making him at least a little less
horrible
outside of the fact the soul that's he's
creating are absolutely horrifying
like moreau we don't really know much
about heisenberg's past
that said i do have a question for all
of you as claudia beneviento had the
berengario chalice in her coffin with
her
i interpreted that to mean there was a
familial relation there
baron gaario is one of the founders and
we know of three others
father nikola guglielmo and cesare
do you think they have any relation to
our lords or was it just a coincidence
that someone of the beneviento family
would take particularly well with the
kadu
and thus we wrap up the lore of the
major lords of resident evil
village who is your favorite to
encounter or perhaps least favorite
personally i love donna benoviento and
everything about her ghostliness and the
dolls and just the aryan creepy factor
of it
and i love digging into the background
of lady dimitresk
even if it meant i had to try to
pronounce her name for a quarter of the
video
if you enjoyed this video let us know by
liking and subscribing and let me know
if there's anything you think i missed
in the comments below
like do we know anything more about
claudia let us know and i'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
you